no ketchup hopefully today I can finally
get through to them these are some of
your guests all I'd like to hear is just
nothing but the plain truth when give
these owners an insight to what you're
paying for so let's start with you I'll
tell you the room was very disappointing
we look for historic buildings when we
go places and this was just a shame it
was like it was neglected it was run
down to the ground before we purchased
this place stop blaming people madam
please she goes inside to your
experience well when we came in we
actually came in the back way this dark
hallway where the confounders
yeah dungeon yeah I entered that way I
mean it was like coming through an
entrance to prison yeah madam please I
have severe asthma and allergies dusting
the top of the doorways and just caked
and white Boston it went beyond a
comfort issue this went to a health
hazard issue
I was literally worried about my
fiancees safety the last thing this
place needs is some kind of you know
wrongful death liable
would any of you come back to stay here
absolutely now not one of you thank you
take care thank you I'm so sorry the
complaints from guests are obvious
things that a hotel owner should be
taken care of but these girls haven't
got a clue or a general manager do you
honestly think that you are capable of
running this hotel when I want something
bad enough and when I have my mind up to
it I always I always accomplish at 32
years of age tell me one thing that
you've accomplished in your life on your
own it worked when I was 14 at a fast
food place are you serious you want me
to get impressed with that no no but I'm
just saying
Vanda do you honestly think that you and
your big sister are capable of running
this hotel I want to say yes but I just
my head says no I feel like a knife had
just been running to my heart
but I can run this place by myself
you have to be honest with yourself I
think we can make it with the positive
reinforcement that I use I would [ __ ]
myself asking you to run my dog up the
hill let alone a hotel
[Music]